Well, I've mentioned this on my story
before. This isn't me that promoted him.
He basically made a chunk to Snapchat
account. He made people believe that
that was my account. He promoted a guy
called Zayn Dills, which has been
scamming people. This person, if he's a
Muslim or a Muslim, whoever his name is,
you've just done me a favor. You took my
wealth. I'll go in contact with the
bank. That money is going to be returned
back to me. And even if it wasn't, thank
you very much.
This is one video. If you care about the
dunya more than a, skip it. By one
donation, you're going to help 1.8
million people in need. 551,000 people
who have been fed through the emergency
food aid. You are going to be sponsoring
4,200 orphans. You will be helping
250,000 people in Gaza. You'll be
helping 123,000 people to be fed through
our Kulmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one um 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya and you will see every penny that
you give on your decision is yours. The
link is there. Donate now.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
hope you guys are well in. So me being a
misogynistic, abusive man, which you
guys obviously saw in my picture how I
was abusing my wife by looking after the
kids while she was having hot chocolate.
So I thought let me add her to abuse
another abuse and uh you know be an
extra misogynistic man that I'm accused
of. So I thought and buy her bag you
know with this kind of stuff obviously
you know here and there I treat her but
anyway so so my wife's come and said
there is obviously uh an account that is
owned by Chunks which we thought it was
owned by Chunks that is endorsing this
guy called Zay Deals. So we're going to
give you the names inshallah and we
don't want you guys to get scammed. I
got in contact with Chunks and he told
me the following which we're going to
watch for ourselves. But it reminds me
of the story of because as you guys know
guys, I don't do videos for the sake of
you know some people come and say to me,
"Oh, you just talk about drama." I'm
like, "Brother, I'm talking about
someone doing evil. How is that drama?
It's enjoying the good and forbidden
evil." Like everyone thinks everything's
drama. I don't do videos for the sake of
it. Every video I do is either Quran or
some kind of reminder. So Omar once a
man stole something from young boy. and
he ran and Omar shouted after him and
said, "Oh boy, just know that I have
forgiven you." Yes. Why? Because he was
more concerned about the thieves
hereafter. Now, we're going to go to
straight to this Trunks thing and then
I'm going to give you guys a reminder.
So, I got in contact with Trunks and
this is what he had to say and um you
know, he said that there's a fake
account that's gone around and I want to
raise awareness to these guys. Please be
careful cuz I did tell my wife, I said,
"Are you sure that this is um a scam?"
She said, "No, I don't think it is.
Chunks given." I said, "Are you sure?"
etc. She said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, this
that, etc." Even when I was making the
payment, I said, "Look, are you sure?"
She's like, "Yeah." And obviously, I was
busy with, etc. And I thought, "You know
what? No problem. Uh, there was a bag
that she wanted." And I thought, "Let me
get that back." So, I sent the money to
some guy called, let's open it for
ourselves, and then we'll go to Chunks.
His name is uh George William Kib, if
I'm not mistaken. And I sent the money
to him. So, we don't know who he is, but
he goes under the name on Snapchat as
Zane Deals. Uh, report him, guys. If you
can try to find as much details about
this scammer, this dirt bag stealing
people's wealth. And alhamdulillah, let
me tell you something. You didn't harm
me. You know what? At the end of the
day, the risk that you was going to
earn, you earned in a haram way. That
risk was going to reach you.
Alhamdulillah, I got in contact with my
bank and my bank is going to take the
money back. So, yes, and we're exposing
you. So, here is what Chunks had to say.
Inshallah, let's go to that. So, I
contacted the check and I said, "Alam,
bro, urgent. Please reply. Someone
called Zayn who who I've been told you
was in a video with him and promoted has
been has taken money for a bag. I
purchased and disappeared. He's deleted
and blocked me and hasn't sent anything
back. He said, "Wlaykum salam. Uh, who's
the same brother? Which video am I in it
with?" So, I sent him this voice note.
Okay. So, so basically, um, from what
I've heard, basically my wife u said
that she saw a video with you and him on
your Snap saying that he does deals on
Louis Vuitton and stuff like that. Um,
and I just wanted to buy her a gift. And
I told her, I said, "Look, are you sure?
You know, do you know this guy?" Oh,
yeah. This I said, "Okay, no problem.
So, I'll show you some screenshots
inshallah." I sent the money and bro,
he's blocked me. He's blocked my wife
and it's just cuz I said, "Look, when
she she mentioned you, I said, "Okay,
then you know it's legit." Um, and
probably you don't know about as well,
but let me try to find out. Um, I'll
send you his account and let me know if
this is correct. This is what I've been
told. So, that's what I sent him. Send
him the screenshots, which you can see
on the screen. Uh, this is um my wife
messaging her, him saying, "Have you got
an update? It's supposed to be delivered
Tuesday. Uh, I ordered from you last
Monday and still haven't heard nothing
from you. This is unprofessional. you've
told me twice you are going to chase it
up but you never uh you got back to me
and you're still online posting stories
and then he blogged my wife
and so yeah so as you can see and then
he sent this thing chunks which saying
that he made a post about this I think 9
weeks ago which is PSA there's a fake
Snapchat account with a name chunks
promoting random dodgy account telling
people to get deals it's not my account
I have no session with account and I got
obviously so angry and I was like you
know it's my wife look you don't you
don't listen to me okay when I told you
listen to me you know that's why sisters
yes your husband is the leader listen to
him okay not misogyny alhamdulillah
there's some things he might sus out and
know that you may not in this instance
it was myself so he showed me the
account so which you guys can see that's
his account and that's the scammer's
account as you guys can see uh so I want
you guys to report it inshallah to
Snapchat as fraud and scam and this is
what uh Chunks had to say
>> brother I've mentioned this on my story
before this isn't me that promoted him.
You won't be able to find a video of me
and this guy standing next to each other
because I don't know him. He basically
made a chunk to Snapchat account. You
can see my one is the verified one with
the yellow tick. His one is the fake
one. He made people believe that that
was my account. He promoted a guy called
Zane deals which has been scamming
people nonstop. But I have no
affiliation with the guy. I've never
promoted the guy. So it's nothing got to
do with me, brother. Sorry that's
happened, man.
>> Yeah. So and I said off, okay, um I'm
going to make a raise. When I said do
you give me permission to play the
voice? No. said no problem.
Alhamdulillah. Yes. And raise a
beautiful brother. May Allah bless and
preserve him. Met his father in bring
cross um a couple of years ago.
Alhamdulillah. So guys, what
[clears throat] do we learn from this?
What's the lessons? Like I said before,
I don't leave videos for drama. It's
benefits. When somebody steals your
wealth, guys, you need to understand
something. When robberies and still this
kind of stuff happen. Number one, I'm
going to say guys, well, like I'll be
honest with you. Glad titans. I know of
a a a brother who lost quarter of a
million pounds. Quarter of a million
pounds. And his reaction shocked me. He
was like, "You know what?
Alhamdulillah." And I was like, "What?"
Like, like I'm not money motivated. I
don't give a crap. I'll be honest. I do
not care about money. So I was a bit
like, "Okay, a million pounds." He was
like and I said, "Subhan Allah." You
know, that's what Allah says in the
remembrance of Allah do hearts find
peace. When you have true to and in
Allah subhana wa ta'ala in his days he's
thinking call a million pounds on your
makyama that's going to be returned back
to me in ways I would wish that everyone
robbed me every day. That's what the
prophetam told us. If you saw the people
who were deeply tested you will if you
saw the rewards they get you would wish
that your flesh was taken piece by piece
along those lines if you knew the
reward. Everything makes sense when we
believe in hereafter.
When we calculate our calculation to the
hereafter, everything makes sense from
the situation in Gaza which is sad from
whatever is happening around the world
from Sudan. Everything makes sense cuz
these people are people in. And this is
the reason why guyshed is so important
to understand and make your
calculations. A billion years ahead, a
trillion years ahead everything makes
sense. when you are tested, when someone
wrongs you, when this happens, when
you're like, you know what, calculation
of the hereafter. So this person, if
he's a Muslim or a Muslim, whoever his
name is, you've just done me a favor.
I'm doing this video not to just have a
go at you, just to warn people not to
get scammed. Of course, you shouldn't
willingly go out there and get scammed.
Hey, you robbed me so I can get No, no,
no. You'll be blamed worthy of that.
However, you took my wealth. I'll go in
contact with the bank. That money is
going to be returned back to me. And
even if it wasn't, thank you very much.
Just like, you know, it's so
interesting. Look how Allah works. Just
as these radical toxic feminists who are
Quran rejectors now basically they
reject Quran anyone I'm not pointing out
specifically anyone that rejects Quran
is a kafir and they're promoting
Quranist which are kaf is fivestar grade
a kufar now they are promoting Quranist
alhamdulillah exposed to them when they
came out with a picture of me and my
wife yes again thank you thank you every
time like Allah says you proah pl and
Allah is the best of plers you put that
out you only worked in my favor
got a couple of second wife proposals
which I have to say sister. No, thank
you very much. Yeah. Okay. I had to say
I understand. Yes. You know um you know
you know you might want to you know have
me you know walk in a new drink of
chocolate but you know inshallah I'll
give you um someone. Okay.
Alhamdulillah. I'm I'm not interested.
Thank you very much. Yeah. Subhan Allah.
And I was like wow. And even with the
situation same thing with the thief. You
came in. You didn't rob from me. You
robbed from yourself. You didn't look
into something. You didn't rob anything
from me habibi. Okay. Don't think like
you know taken you've done me a favor.
you've added to my bank account in the
hereafter. You took from my bank account
of the dunya but you added to my bank
account in the hereafter in ways where I
would say alhamdulillah
that this man stole £500. Alhamdulillah
Allah that this person wronged me on
Allah is going to come and say by the
way the recumbent for this is this oh
Jenna damn
okay I'm joking [laughter]
oh this that I'm going to get that woo
alhamdulillah I can go Jenna without any
being questioned alhamdulillah I wish
they exp I I wish they wronged me more
and abused me more subhan Allah so guys
when you make these calculations make
the calculations according to the
hereafter you know why this is the
beauty of Islam When I was a
disbeliever, I didn't have these
concepts. Believe in Allah. Allah is my
provider. Allah, I was worried about
this, my money. Where's it going to come
from? Wallah, I have full trust in
Allah. I do not remember that since I've
come to Islam, 13 years that I have
ever, ever woken up and said, where am I
going to eat tomorrow? Where am I going
to stay? I don't have money in my
account.
Wall brothers and sisters, put your
trust in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah will take care of you. Allah takes
care of billions of species. It's the
greatest disrespect to think Allah
wouldn't take care of it that you have
to go and steal other people's wealth
which is actually stealing from your own
self. That's why brothers and sisters
the link that we the the fundraiser
thing we put in the beginning. Yes.
Don't think and I want you guys to
donate to this cause inshallah to help
one um keep it 100 and your donations
are going to go in keeping this charity
100 to millions of people in Gaza,
Sudan, around the world to benefit and
be helped. Brothers and sisters, don't
think when you donate you are taken away
from your wealth. Rather, when you don't
donate, you are stealing from your
wealth. Allah's messenger wasallam said
will never make you poor. Saddak gets in
the way of calamity. Cure your sick with
your isan for you. Brothers and sisters,
I just want to say to this thief, thank
you for doing me this favor and all
these other people and your in get our
h. And be warned, brothers and sisters,
that's where they're called Zane deals
or whatever it is for that matter.
verify, check, double check in. And
yeah, it was a lesson learned for my
wife and a lesson learned for you guys.
Inshallah, brothers chunks, may Allah
bless preserve you for allowing me to
use that voice note. Till next time.
light with what better cat.